I want you to look on to pot D because D
makes it quite a bit trickier okay
what's different in Part D that uh well
there's a couple of things what kinds of
things you see them different between a
and D any suggestions yep okay firstly
we have some negatives don't we okay so
maybe we are gonna put the zero in the
milk any other differences anyone else
yep well you just you just gradually um
you might have noticed you know here we
had to rewrite this as Four Thirds okay
but then we were kind of done and then
we could compare them all nicely right
but the numbers in non-party let me just
write them out they're not nearly as
nice are they - no tents what kind of
problem are we presented with here okay
we did we did notice I how many Nick
[ __ ] I got I've got one two three one
half of them are negative okay but
there's a bigger problem
yes yeah that's right the denominators
which is what we looked at last lesson
wasn't it right there really messed up
okay ten five - for another ten okay so
in order to compare them I need to have
out what's it called to compare these
what do I mean our common denominator
all have to know anything about what
them - good saying so I'm gonna use the
lowest common multiple what is the
lowest common multiple of two four five
and ten what's the smallest number that
can fit all those in it's 20 isn't it
I'm gonna say yeah okay so let's write
equivalent fractions for all of them
add 20 out of 20 out of 20
20 okay so from here to here the
numerator has doubled in size it's gone
from 10 to 20 so what do I do
write the denominator has doubled in
size so what I do to the numerator the
same thing yeah I double it it's
negative 7 so it should become negative
14
excellent okay now this time different
denominators do something different
happens it got bigger by a factor of 4
so I should do the same thing to the
numerator 2 times 4 is 8
good this time from 2 to 20 I multiply
by 10 so my minus 1 negative was 10
okay you just seen the pattern right
here I should multiply by 5 and here I
should multiply by 2 just like the stuff
okay now we're in the same boat that we
were here all common Domino's now I can
draw the thing okay so so yeah I want to
draw this out but we do have positives
and negatives so I'm gonna stick 0 in
there okay now you've got to give
yourself enough space so that you could
reach all the way up to 18 and 20 up and
all the way down to negative 14 so my
dots are gonna be quite small and so
much yours okay so I'm gonna try it
okay now you might notice I'm not sure
how many of you do this it's just to
help you you know on your ruler like
your actual ruler let me find a good one
here Jeff okay on your ruler to help you
um read the measurements well right
they've got millimeter markings but some
of the markings are longer than others
right do you notice that the centimeter
markings are the longest but every half
a centimeter they're also bit longer
now I've just done something similar
like that every five so that I don't you
know miss count if they're all the same
size I might miss count 17 or 18 is very
close together okay so that just kind of
helps you write I'm going to do the same
thing the other way make sure they're
all delicious then
okay now last time we wrote all the
numbers just to be sure but I think this
is a good example of where writing all
the numbers number one would take ages
number two because it's so close
together it's really hard to squeeze it
in right so that's just through the ones
we need we want negative 14 or 20 [ __ ]
that's the smallest one that's all the
way over here isn't it okay so yeah yeah
be the second last one because I've done
my markers of five have an iron okay so
that's negative five or twenty negative
ten on twenty this last one will be
negative 59 20 so I want that one there
it is
okay now it's a good idea to take things
off as you go so that you know which
ones you've done which ones you haven't
where's eight yeah it's gonna be able to
hear right there's ten eight and I think
you're getting the hang of it right
shall we just finish it off you can
finish it up right
and 18 I just wished right
all right okay yeah yeah all right now
I've put all of this so that you can see
the scale is all the same right but
these are all the equivalent fractions
right what we were provided was this so
even though they are the same it's kind
of useful to put this as what it was
equal to right but it's helpful so you
can count the right number of notches if
you like
what was this I'd say no I'll tell you
why because if a question said put on
the number line we are looking for your
ability to compare these fractions
together now assuming you've got them in
the right spots right this one here all
the stuff in green that was really the
hard part wasn't it right it was making
sure we have all the right distances
we've got to scale right and we can
compare them properly okay
this part here getting the back in the
same nose higher that I've seen on the
cake but it is nice to include because
that's what we were asked all right